this is my black history it used to be a
black history month poster but i you
know crossed out the month and per year
because
black history is happening all year
anthony crawford worries he could lose
his job
he teaches creative writing at millwood
high in oklahoma city
where a state law is set to ban certain
teachings of race and history
since the murder of george floyd a year
ago the subject matter in mr crawford's
english class
has focused increasingly around race and
racism in america
did george floyd change the
conversations happening in oklahoma
schools
people got to see um you know
this man put his knee on somebody's neck
and he watched this man die
so he changed that whole situation
changed a lot of things that going on
around schools on may 7 oklahoma's
republican governor signed a new law
that could have consequences for schools
like millwood high
we can and should teach this history
without
labeling a young child as an oppressor
or requiring he or she
feel guilt or shame based on their race
or sex
it's widely seen as a ban on critical
race theory a decades-old
academic study of the legacy of racism
and inequality
in our legal and social systems but a
growing chorus of conservatives
used the phrase to describe diversity
training and historical teachings
they argue are divisive do you actually
teach critical race theory here
i don't i didn't know critic what
critical race theory was
it's not something that i you know even
think about when i'm in class talking
about these things
is this law going to change teacher
behavior it has to
because now if a teacher don't want to
lose their job okay well i don't want to
go there i don't want to talk about this
knowing that it could be possibly
a lawsuit or a possible way for me to
lose my job so i know a lot of teachers
is going to move a lot differently
millwood is a majority black high school
its superintendent is staunchly opposed
to the statewide ban
there's so many things that these kids
know about who they are
that come up in school that have never
been protected
and so i i don't feel like
this law
represents every child i feel like this
law is only representing a few
and those few are white children
politics we're just going to say
politics
education it's mr crawford's style to
let his students debate race
intensely racism is
when you can take all these entities
that make up a society
and only can be controlled by one ethnic
group
you cannot talk about american history
without speaking about racism
you cannot do it from the beginning it
started with slavery
not just with african-americans started
slavery with
native americans this is why most people
feel like they never go away
but you know my thing is why not be that
generation that makes it go away
but my thing starts with education it's
being taught
now it's being questioned it's being
taught it's not being taught it's a
white
watched version of what the wrong
history is are you in this class
yeah but this is not white washed at all
this fight over race and education stems
from the events of last year when mass
demonstrations swept through the country
the outrage over george floyd's murder
sparked a re-evaluation of diversity
inclusion and history
in almost every workplace school and
university in america
in september then president trump signed
an executive order banning diversity
trainings in federal agencies
calling the ideas divisive and
un-american
critical race theory is being forced
into our
children's schools it's being imposed
into
workplace trainings and it's being
deployed
to rip apart friends neighbors
and families trump's order was
overturned on president biden's first
day in office
but the fight went local over the last
few months
lawmakers in more than a dozen states
have advanced measures to ban the
teaching of critical race theory
just one year after the murder of george
floyd sparked mass
protests and a reckoning over diversity
and inclusion
in many american schools representative
kevin west was one of the lead authors
of oklahoma's bill
no teacher shall require or
make part of a course the following
concepts
an individual by virtue of his or her
race or sex
bears responsibility for actions
committed
in the past by other members of the same
race or sex i've certainly never heard a
teacher say those things which is part
of
the surprise i think right at the need
for the bill
we can we can agree or we can disagree
on how far this is happening
in oklahoma but the
the whole bill boils down to
should we ever under any circumstances
teach that based on your race or your
sex
you're inherently racist or sexist
what's going to happen to teachers who
want to talk about the long documented
history of inequality in the country
we're not saying that you can't teach
about this stuff
we're saying that you're not going to go
in with the predetermined notion
that because you are
a white child that you are inherently
racist uh and tying that
to the the curriculum you know such as
slavery or something like that
kimberly crenshaw one of the founding
scholars of critical race theory
says that's not an honest
characterization of her work
i've been trying to tell people for at
least six
months that the effort to respond
to the reckoning of last summer
was going to metastasize into a backlash
and in september when
then president trump stepped forward and
said that it was critical race theory
i thought okay so they found their
boogeyman
critics of your work say that that's
your analysis that's your opinion and
that doesn't belong in the classroom is
it possible to talk about u.s history
without systemic racism
u.s history is systemic racism
how do you talk about genocide
how do you talk about enslavement how do
you talk about those things
in ways that are guaranteed to make
everyone feel
happy and fuzzy these are not happy
and fuzzy stories as these bills
pass around the country what do you
think will happen
before we know it students of color
as well as white students are going to
have an education
that is less robust than we have even
right now
this is this is a runaway train
and a lot of people are on it and have
no idea what the destination is
hi thank you for making time to come
jenny white is a parent of five
she's worked with lawmakers behind
oklahoma's legislation
i feel like there are people that are
judging me for the color of my skin
because i've seen
things that are coming out of schools
where you know i'm supposed to apologize
for my whiteness and i'm
supposed to apologize for this or that
or the other thing
now you're going toward you know
demonizing a population
just like we demonized another
population and that's not going to be a
good outcome either
she doesn't think this bill goes far
enough when i was in school we used to
call america the melting pot
you could be black or white or yellow or
it didn't matter it didn't matter
what country you came from america was
the place that welcomed you with open
arms
is it possible that some of those folks
you grew up around
from different backgrounds even at that
time weren't seeing america through the
same lens
that you saw it i have friends from all
kinds of different places and
that's just they've had kind of the same
feeling about it that i have
teresa manning is a former trump
administration official
i think something has to be done to
defend the country from this
psychological warfare
you see this as a war it's certainly
psychological warfare
absolutely psychological to demoralize
the western
peoples we can't be that evil the
country
or that evil of civilization if so many
seek to
live here can we have a future in this
country if we're not going to be able to
have these really uncomfortable and
sometimes messy sometimes acrimonious
conversations
about race and history in america i
you know yelling fire in a crowded
theater has never been
viewed as protected in speech um speech
that's treasonous during wartime
is is not protected we get to defend
ourselves
from attacks on the country when you're
listing off diversity and inclusion and
all of these efforts are apparently
under one insidious umbrella
and the people involved in many cases
don't even know
or or or appear to be aware that they're
a part of this
do you see why people would see that as
a straw man argument
i don't actually we're getting a lot of
reports
of a neo-racism a new attempt
to have people see themselves in terms
of their skin color
and not as americans we're seeing it all
over so
uh where there's smoke there's fire in
crawford's classroom his teenage
students
managed to debate history and race their
whole thing was
we shouldn't teach this in class because
one it makes other certain ethnicities
feel bad
and that sucks i'm sorry that sucks it
gets heated
but it never escalates to war even
garrett
the only white student in class holds
his own not you at all
i felt bad but i can't feel bad for
something that i didn't do
it's your own person you can't hate
someone because of what
their parents did we feel y'all we
appreciate the ones that don't feel the
same way as
the racist rules but we still do see
more racism in the world than the
come together feeling we have to face
the facts that it's never going to be
like that
it's never good there's never going to
be doing that part of what's animated
this legislation is that there are
people who believe
that it's not right for students to be
put in a position in class where they
may be left feeling guilty
do you think that people sometimes leave
this classroom or leave discussions like
this
feeling that way and does that make the
law worthwhile
i've been in the history class and we've
talked about things like this
intensely like this and i've been the
only black kid
in that class and i did like you said
yeah i would leave the class i would go
sit in the bathroom for
15-20 minutes and because i i mean
the only black kid around a bunch of
white folks talking about it made me
uncomfortable so i do
see where you're coming from about that
does anyone care about
the comfortability of black people no
one obviously they don't care
well i'm not saying that you don't
specifically do you have any faith that
this
country can come to an agreement about
its history
we have to be able to acknowledge what
has happened before we can reconcile
but racism has been weaponized
anti-racism has been turned into the
boogeyman
and until we are willing to say no we're
not going to allow that to happen
this is bigger than a particular moment
a particular political party
until we're ready to say that it will
remain
an open question about whether this
wound
will ever be healed
antonia hilton nbc and sky news oklahoma
city